I was Finding work in Los Angeles as a
director different from other places
yeah that's a good question so I've
lived quite a few different places
around the country
um
I just grew up in Portland Oregon I
lived in Nashville for many years I went
to I lived in Eastern Washington I lived
back in Portland and attended to La
every single city in the country has
their own little interesting if you do
film it has their own little interesting
Hub
um
for the most part most cities have like
some sort of Industry that keeps it
going
um
like in Portland and Seattle there's you
know you got Microsoft and Nike and
Adidas excuse me a bunch of ad agencies
there
so the for the most part A lot of the
work that people do
is in that
realm so I mean you can have a great
career just doing Microsoft videos and
you know there's no shame in that and
that's sort of the industry that it's
going to be and
the only difference between that and
like in Nashville is replace Microsoft
with music videos
it's the same kind of thing probably a
smaller more tight-knit Film Community
um doing similar kind of stuff and also
great careers can be had by doing that
uh I've recently been doing a lot of
work in Florida and Tampa and there
their industry is um
HGTV I believe yeah it's based there so
they a lot of the people that work there
work there at doing and then I think
Ashley Furniture makes a lot of their
commercials there so almost everyone
I've worked with usually has spent some
time working in that little Realm
so moving from City to City that's not a
Hub City
that's the biggest difference it's
really just okay what industry is here
and then you know now if you're talking
indie film The indie film markets in
those towns look identical
which is kind of funny and there's
almost this funny little divide between
those who are doing the corporate work
like doing the Microsoft stuff or the Ad
Agency world and then there's the Indie
filmmakers over here and usually those
two worlds don't intersect that much in
a weird way
now
I think there's a middle step as well
and that would be the Hub cities cities
like New Orleans and Atlanta and New
Mexico so in those cities tons and tons
of work is happening uh if you are below
the line
any kind of crew position makeup artist
and
whatever gaffer grips ACS all of that
stuff you will work you can work as much
as you want and you're working on great
big stuff you're probably going to be
able to really do quite well and that is
a if you want to work in movies and
even if you do want to be a director but
you're still you're starting out and
you're working your way up the ladder
those could be a great cities to go to
because it's it's like
I can I have a friend who just moved to
New Orleans a few years ago and he told
me when he first moved there he couldn't
believe
how much work was actually happening
they were doing a big movie and their
base camp where all the catering was
where you met in the morning was
actually shared by two other gigantic
Productions three of them sharing one
huge base camp like that's insane I
can't even imagine that and he said that
this boy if you live here you could work
as much as you want full-time year-round
full union rates all of it like
you could just clean house and work and
work and work and work work
so that does exist in LA but it's a lot
harder to
to get
um
because everybody moves to LA
to pursue film so
everybody's a filmmaker you're if you
came from
Kansas City and you were really good at
and you had that corner of the market on
the whatever's in Kansas City
you are really nothing special when you
get to LA like there will be it's not
that you're not talented it's just that
everybody does that here like
everybody's like that
la
is those of you who don't live here like
the biggest difference is that La is
where the decisions happen so if you are
above the line
writers directors mainly and actors who
want to be on larger things
you got to be here
so getting
on those projects in an above the line
position is a whole different game than
anything else that you have to worry
about in other cities
all you got to do in say a Portland to
get work is
you're probably going to bid on it
by against a couple of production houses
that you're probably friends with you're
gonna hire them anyway once you get the
job so it doesn't matter but you're
probably baiting on it in some sort of
way uh
then you know the budgets are not gonna
yeah they may be all right but they're
not going to be Millions more than
likely
um
and yeah it's going to be a little a fun
little corporate thing and it's going to
be lower pressure I mean high pressure
for the client but overall the grand
scope of life not that big of a deal La
it's 100 different than that
you can work here
and most people do when they get here if
you're trying to get here and work as a
filmmaker yes there is work to be had is
it work that you want
that's the question that's the real
trick because most of the people that he
move here
well you got to work somewhere and
It generally will come down to do I work
waiting tables or do I work anywhere I
can get into the industry
um you know and that might be an
assistant to
some writer you're not you're not
writing anything but you're their
assistant getting their coffee it might
be most of the people I know go into
reality somewhere some way is it the
dream job absolutely not do they like it
probably not for the most part but
that's there's a lot of that kind of
work below the line stuff you might be
running a camera you might be producing
but it's
is not the dream job at all so
it's a weird almost like purgatory
that exists here because this is giant
machine
and that's the best way to define it La
is an industry most of these other towns
are communities that's a huge Gulf of a
difference so when you're here you get
you can get stuck in this filmmaker
Purgatory of like constantly working on
stuff you don't like like reality shows
or whatever
and then you're you're making some money
and you're surviving but you cannot
figure out how to cross the threshold
from that to all right I'm gonna hire
you because you're a great director to
direct on this television show or Helm
the next Marvel film like that's a
that's a much weirder barrier to cross
and that doesn't exist and if you don't
live here you're probably not going to
have to deal with that unless you're
incredibly lucky unless you just happen
to be the one guy who won that lottery
ticket and gets discovered
by the president of Disney and brings
you over
otherwise forget it it's probably not
going to happen so
that's a real trick a real weird
most filmmakers you meet in LA are in
purgatory they're not weird
they're they're all writing something
they're all developing something they're
all all of us everyone I know they have
the thing they want to do they have no
idea how to get over that bridge but
they all want to do it
um
I think if you're going to move here
that is an important thing to understand
because you've got to work somewhere you
got to make a living
um
and I think if you understand going in
that your life will probably be taken
over by
uh
that purgatory
you have to continue then to keep
working on your own craft when you're
not on set doing this other thing over
here that is the key to figuring it out
is I've I gotta live I gotta make a
living somewhere
putting a barrier around that and going
when I'm not doing that then I'm going
to work on my thing every writer I know
who's got an agent they their agents
always tell them or managers tell them
the same thing yeah I know you're
working all day on that TV show and I
know you're tired but if you want
anything if you want to have a career of
your own at all you have to keep working
on your own stuff on the side they tell
them that straight up and every writer I
know does that they'll work all day on
their thing when they get home
they eat their dinner they sit in there
and they write for a couple hours on
their own passion projects and that is
how they break through that is how they
keep going forward
it's harder you know especially when you
get married you start having kids life
starts getting in the way and they find
the energy to do that is is the biggest
challenge
that leads me to my next question
because we have a quote from you that we
got from our 2019 interview that we did
with you what you do in the dark when no
one is looking
that's where your medal is
that's how you get better
do you still Embrace this idea yeah no
question about it I
yes it is
when you're in your when you're young
when you're in your teens in your 20s we
are all going to school
right we and then when we get out of
college most of us stop
why is that
why do we all stop learning
and taking classes and honing why do we
do that what is there is there like did
somebody on high like
flick a switch and say you've learned
all that you need to know no no
um
but we seem to always do that and the
only way to do that is
the self
um discipline to continue on your own
when no one's looking all right
now not on Facebook
what can I learn what am I lacking in my
directing skills
gee I really suck at working with actors
I should probably get better at that how
do I do that well maybe read a couple of
books or take you know that's that's
where the real yes you you must do that
if you want to be the best you have to
do that
I was I was working on a show recently
in this last year
and in the last couple of years I was in
a writing class and uh
I started the writing class because I
just wanted to get better at crafting
stories it just understanding how
storytelling works on the most basic
level
um it was an area that I felt was
lacking in my own journey and so I yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this so at night
I was
taking this class
landed this job and I'm directing all
these episodes and the executive
producer pulls me aside
and he says because you know there's
been a few people that have come up to
me and say and and said to me
why is the guy who's directing your show
taking a writing class at night
and he said to me he goes and they're
telling me this they're asking me this
like it's a negative and I said to them
are you crazy it's because he knows that
life's a journey that you have to keep
sharpening and honing and pushing all
the time otherwise you stagnate is that
he thinks that's why he's got the job
because he knows that not because he
goes ah I know everything
um it was such an interesting thing to
hear uh but that that's an insight into
how most of us think
like we get to a point where we think
we've mastered it and if you think that
you probably haven't
and do you think that that goes back to
what we talked about sort of I guess a
snobbery in this business because at
what point has anybody finished with
learning something yeah I think I can I
think I think a lot of the the
traditional snobbery that we think of
when we think of Hollywood
I mean I think ultimately stems from
insecurity
you know this idea that
maybe I'm not if they were to be honest
in the dark maybe I'm not as good as I
think I am Maybe
I mean a lot of the people that have
treated me poorly were people that were
threatened but I mean I'm not saying I'm
all that I'm just saying all of us have
experienced that where you just there's
someone that you run into that treats
you badly
and you almost know on this gut level
that it's like I think they're
threatened by me I don't even know why
I'm not trying to like hurt them I'm not
trying to beat them but they are viewing
me like I'm trying to be like so it all
stems from this deep deep insecurity I
think
um
that's really a shame and a lot of the
people I think who are the worst
offenders of that are the people that
don't continue to grow
they feel like this is where you'll hear
it too you'll hear it when it when
someone will complain about the young
coming up and taking their jobs that's
where you can really spot it that is
someone who has
uh it's a it's a growth mindset versus a
fixed mindset it's a fixed mindset is
someone who believes that Talent is
something you're born with
a growth mindset is some someone that
believes that Talent is something that
can be learned by continuing repeated
Behavior
now you may have a knack a propensity
for math or photography but that doesn't
mean you're a genius
out of the womb you know it has to be
cultivated and worked the people that
use those terms like
those kids don't know what they're doing
they don't want to hire an expert
well no it's not that it's probably not
that at all it's because they're hungry
they're they're coming up and and
fighting for it to learn and they're
probably they're the ones watching film
courage interviews to get better the
people that are angry are not they're
not they're just not
now they're all going to comment on on
this one and say what is that kind of
but uh it's
yeah that's uh I think that's where that
comes from though I that
and I think if you are one of those
people and you're constantly feeling
this threat
uh it's time to take a serious look at
where you are standing and where those
feelings are really coming from are you
feeling threatened because you're
worried about your job
and if you're worried about your job why
are you so worried is it because you
think that they're going to discover you
for being a fraud maybe or is it because
um I don't know like
there's many reasons why that could be I
just think
it's it's time for self-reflection time
so you can find yourself in that
position I think we can all think back
to when we were threatened of someone I
mean I can picture being 14 and being
incredibly threatened of somebody and
now that I look back on it it was
because yeah I was afraid they were
gonna you know was my little part-time
job and then I thought they were going
to take my job and they weren't they
were just there for the summer yeah
before they went to college but you know
it's if we look back to things when when
we did it to you know we can say okay
well that was why I couldn't say hi to
this you know and then and then when it
happens to you in reverse then you go
okay that's a fair point it is a fair
point because yes I've I've struggled
with that too there's certainly
directors have come up that I'm like
frustrated with like
but if I'm being honest I would say it's
because
I I could even I mean it's been it's
happened I'll see some 20 year old
do something that I can't do
that bothers me
because you know whatever and it's who
knows they spent all their high school
years we're learning After Effects and
they just got really good at doing VFX
and they're coming out of the gate with
some amazing short it's like
how in the world did he and I feel
threatened by that and I want to treat
them badly because of that I think it's
just uh that's not
instead wouldn't it be better and I'm
talking to myself here but wouldn't it
be better for me to take a look at this
person and go
maybe we should team up
wouldn't it be cool to like take someone
who's got that desire and has the skill
that I struggle with and to bring them
on to my team and we can work together I
mean this is a collaborative art after
all should isn't that the way it's
supposed to work like you're taking all
these artists who are hungry do you know
how much that would mean to him or her
if you did that and how hard they would
work because chances are they are
looking at you as you know a veteran or
whatever
wanting that approval and and just
begging for a shot
um
I think it would be a much healthier way
of looking at it
because think about it that's what we
all want that's what we all wanted we
all want someone to believe in us and
not be threatened by us and give us a
shot so
um
you know
and it actually makes me wonder if the
those of us who feel threatened who feel
angry who who if we feel like well no
one ever helped me why should I help
them or maybe I don't
have anything to give them because I
never did get a shot so they're gonna
just surpass me
you know those are all
hard questions to
to process
um
I think if you recognize that that's how
you're feeling
it's time for reality check on you know
maybe maybe you have gotten shots and
maybe you are further than you think
maybe you are
someone of influence that does have a
lot to give you know and holding on so
tightly to your position is is I think
it's like a cancer because it because
when you do that this gets back to what
we were talking about originally holding
on to something when it's trying life is
trying to slip past and morph it in your
hands
maybe it could grow into something even
more incredible than you you're
imagining right now
you know like
whenever you start to feel that gut go
yep and hold on to that thing like I
think that's that's a Thai time to like
take a serious look at where you are